[Musique]
quel pays envoient le plus d'ouvriers
agricoles au canada le mexique avec plus
de 25 mille employés temporaires dans
les fermes les mexicains sommes le plus
important contingent de main d'oeuvre
étrangère
d'autres pays fournissent de nombreux
travailleurs chez nous au québec
le guatemala comble près de la moitié
des besoins en main d'oeuvre étrangère
et en ontario après le mexique c'est de
la jamaïque qu'arrivent les employés
agricoles temporaire au canada
l'agriculture est le secteur de
l'économie qui affiche le plus fort taux
d'emploi vacants
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre dans les
fermes canadiennes ne cesse d'augmenter
et doublera d'ici 2029
l' embauche de travailleurs étrangers
temporaires comble 75 % du déficit de la
main d'oeuvre dans les fermes en 2018
cinquante cinq mille travailleurs
étrangers sont venus prêter main forte
aux producteurs agricoles canadiens dont
quatorze mille au québec à travers le
pays
dans 85% des cas il effectué des tâches
dans des fermes maraîchères et dans des
serres c'est l'ontario qui reçoit le
plus grand nombre d'employés étrangers
avec 25000 ont suivi du québec et de la
colombie-britannique